I mean the stores make what like 20
billion dollars in revenue yearly was
part of the goal to increase that
revenue you know it's funny there's
always there's absolutely the business
side always and a lot of that's driven
by you know great products and marketing
and a lot of the things that you really
don't control but the bigger goal for me
now I'm from a tiny town in Indiana and
you know the bigger goal for me was that
I think I think big companies have a
really big responsibility in the future
and I think that in the in the age of
automation and and I was fastest things
are going to change I think we all have
to lean in to what's in our DNA
what is our expertise and how do we you
know what's our role to play in the
communities and whether it's Reese
killing whether it's you know for what
needs we're going to need in the future
so what we should teach Swift coding you
know we need them would love them to
become the next generation I was app
developers so who better than to teach
our coding than the retail stores I mean
you and I've talked about this I mean
you've almost I used the word obligation
do tech companies have an obligation I
think all companies have an obligation
and especially in this day and age I
think that you know again we know how
fast things are going to change we have
to keep pace but then we have to make
sure that everywhere we all have offices
or stores or that it's that we also do
everything we can because everybody you
know you're going through another
evolution everyone's jobs and roles are
going to change anything that can be
automated probably will be